l'impatience de voir donald trump quitté
la maison blanche juste de l'autre côté
de ces barricades s'est exprimée très
tôt ce matin en chansons des bye bye qui
sonnait comme un bon débarras dans cette
place devenue un symbole de la
résistance contre le 45e président des
états unis
j'ai passé quatre ans à manifester dès
lendemain de son investiture lens ni qui
habite washington soulagement palpable
chez ceux et celles qui ont écouté
attendiez gommage cérémonie puis le
discours de joe biden président ces
leçons de la liberté de l'espoir du
retour de la compassion s'extasie ce
floridien liane venue du michigan est
ouest ils n'étaient pas nombreux
le message des autorités un site est
depuis des semaines la population à
suivre l'investiture à la maison en ces
temps de crise sanitaire et de menaces
sécuritaires
mais il en fallait plus pour décourager
ceux et celles bien décidé à vivre sur
place cette investiture qui voit les
états unis en chirurgie air importante
avec une première femme une personne de
couleur à la vice-présidence kamala
harris disent ces deux californiennes
fière qu'elle est représentée leur état
près de la cathédrale où une messe a
lancé la journée d'investiture elle
avait la ferme intention de suivre
autant que faire se peut de joe biden en
cette journée qualifiée d' historique
cette résidente est descendu de son
appartement plutôt que d'y suivre au
chaud la cérémonie en pensant peut-être
l'apercevoir à cette journée chargée
d'espoir ici libéraux radio-canada
washington